━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
内藤忍の資産デザイン研究所メール＜第七百一号2026年9月11日（金）発行＞
資産デザイン研究所メールは、資産運用に役立つ情報を個人投資家の皆様に提供するウィークリー・メールマガジンです。
金融資産だけではなく、不動産をはじめとする実物資産への投資まで、幅広い投資対象を組み合わせる「ハイブリッド投資」の具体的方法を可能な限り客観的な視点でご紹介いたします。
資産デザイン研究所
内藤忍公式ブログ
内藤忍、株式会社資産デザイン研究所は、資産配分などの投資アドバイスは行いますが、金融商品の勧誘・推奨などの投資助言業務は一切行っておりません。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
【残席1名】14日開催！
金利上昇下での不動産投資戦略セミナー （9/14）
12年続く毎回好評の定番セミナー
9月も追加開催決定です
10名限定で東京ミッドタウン六本木で開催
今回は金利上昇下での不動産投資について情報提供いたします
現在の環境下で失敗しない物件の選び方、お金の借り方がわかります
不動産投資未経験者・初心者におススメです
詳しい内容とお申込みはこちらから
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
1　資産デザインのすすめ　〜　こんしゅうの気になるテーマ
2　本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・勉強会のお知らせ
3　読者の質問コーナー
4　内藤忍の「白米ダイエット日記」
5　資産運用日記
6　内藤忍のつぶやき
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜内藤忍の公式ブログ Shinoby`s World コラムタイトル一覧＞
毎日更新している公式ブログの、前回メールマガジン配信以降のコラムです。
こちらから全文をお読みいただけます
9月5日 海外旅行は今やコスパもタイパも悪すぎる
9月6日 アメリカの食事をおいしいと感じない理由は「酸味」
9月7日 日本でライドシェアや自動運転が広がらない理由
9月8日 コンビニおにぎりに感動してしまう日本
9月9日 「11億7千万円」で政治家としての魂を売ってしまった人たち
9月10日 キャンプ未経験者が頼るべきはエーアイとユーチューブ
9月11日 「年利12％の私募債」は詐欺なのか？
それともお宝情報なのか？
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜内藤忍のメディア出演・出版情報＞
【毎月更新】マネックス証券の投資情報サイト「マネクリ」
最新コラムタイトルは
「これから住むべき場所はどう決める？
」
連載一覧はこちらから
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
1　資産デザインのすすめ〜こんしゅうの気になるテーマ
トランプ政権の支持率低下はアメリカ経済にプラス？
トランプ政権に対する米国民の支持率が低迷しています。
このままの状態で11月の中間選挙で共和党が大敗した場合、アメリカ経済はどうなるでしょうか？
私はこれまで経済の不確実性を高めていたトランプ氏の強硬な政権運営に歯止めがかかると考えます。
例えばかんぜいの急激な引き上げや保護主義的政策へのブレーキです。
政権の独断的な方針に議会の監視が強まることで、突発的な制制かんぜいのリスクが大幅に低下します。
これはアメリカで事業を経営する者にとって大きな安心感となります。
また輸入物価の上昇圧力が和らぐことで家庭の消費コスト抑制にもつながり、内需主導の着実な経済成長を支える基盤が整います。
イラン情勢においても政権による突発的な軍事介入や際限のない対イラン制裁強化に対し、議会が予算や権限の面から歯止めがかかります。
原油価格の乱高下やエネルギー供給不安が和らぎ、インフレ抑制と企業コストの安定化に直接寄与します。
地政学的な最悪シナリオへの警戒感が後退することは、グローバル市場全体の投資家心理を改善させる材料となります。
さらに、金融しじょうにとっても外交・内政両面における不確実性の低下はかぶしきしじょうにプラスに作用します。
政権からの政治的圧力が弱まることで中央銀行である米連邦準備制度（エフアールビー）の独立性が維持され、金融しじょうにも安心感が広がります。
アメリカ経済にとってトランプ政権の支持率低下はポジティブな動きと言えるのではないでしょうか。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
2　本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・イベントのご案内
【残席1名】14日開催！
金利上昇下での不動産投資戦略セミナー （9/14）
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
3　読者の質問コーナー
読者からのご質問に、内藤忍がズバリ回答いたします！
Ｑ：東京23区で民泊規制が強化されるようです。
民泊投資にはこれから慎重になった方が良いのでしょうか？
Ａ：ご質問ありがとうございます。
東京23区をはじめとする都心部で民泊規制が強化される動きを踏まえると、これからのこのようなエリアでの民泊投資は慎重にすべきというのが結論です。
単にインバウンドじゅようの高まりや表面上の利回りの高さだけで参入を決めると、予期せぬ撤退や大幅な収支悪化に見舞われるリスクが高まっています。
いっぽうで大都市圏以外に目を向けると、民泊に積極的な自治体も存在します。
地方の観光地や過疎地域では、宿泊施設の不足解消や空き家対策の一環として民泊歓迎の姿勢をとっているエリアがあるからです。
どちらにしても民泊事業において注意すべきなのは規制やルールが事業開始後に急に変更されるリスクです。
近隣住民との摩擦やゴミ問題などのトラブル増加を受けて、これまで規制が緩かった自治体が上乗せ条例を新設したり、管理基準を厳格化したりする事例は珍しくありません。
運営開始後に営業可能日数が削減されると収支計画が根本から崩れてしまうため、あらかじめ法改正や条例変更の可能性を織り込んだ余裕ある資金計画を立てておく必要があります。
万が一民泊として運営できなくなったときのだいたい案、すなわち明確な出口戦略を事前に考えておくことが極めて重要なポイントとなります。
民泊でしか収益が出ないような立地の物件は避け、他の用途でも成立する耐性を持った物件を選ぶことが、こんごの民泊投資における最大の防衛策だと思います。
このコーナーでは読者の方からのご質問に、資産デザイン研究所だいひょう取締役の内藤忍がメールマガジン上で回答いたします。
資産デザイン研究所
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
4　内藤忍の「白米ダイエット日記」
大好きな牡蠣フライカレーで感じる秋の気配
ファストフードのチェーン店の中で最近最も頻繁に出かけているのが、近所にあるカレー店です。
スパイスの効いたカレーが病みつきになる味で、辛さやご飯の量など細かくカスタマイズできるのが気に入っています。
私の場合、ご飯は少し少なめの250g、カレーの辛さは3辛、ほうれん草カレーに豚しゃぶハーフをトッピングするのが定番です。
そして秋から冬にかけて牡蠣フライが登場すると必ずと言って良いほど注文します。
こんしゅう、アメリカから帰って久しぶりにランチに出かけると既に牡蠣フライが始まっていました。
毎回定番の注文に牡蠣フライを2個トッピングで追加です。
出てきたカレーにはいつも卓上にあるトビ辛スパイスというパウダーをたっぷり振りかけます。
これを汗をかきながらハフハフ食べるのがたまりません。
牡蠣フライにはウスターソースを軽くかけてカレーとご飯も一緒にいただきます。
これがまた味変になって最後まで飽きずに食べられます。
合間にらっきょうと福神漬けも忘れてはいけません。
ご飯少なめ、3辛、ほうれん草、豚しゃぶハーフ、牡蠣フライ2個、らっきょうの注文でお会計は1,433円でした。
カレーを食べながら秋の気配を感じるのも何だかシュールです。
いぜんは1000円を超えると高いと思ったココイチですが、異常な物価高のアメリカからの戻ると、このクオリティがこんなに安いのかと感動ものでした。
会社の資本関係がこれから変わるというニュースもありますが、味はいつまでも変わらないでいて欲しいものです。
CoCo壱番屋 晴海トリトン店
東京都中央区晴海1-8-8
03-5144-0558
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
5　資産運用日記
修繕費用がかさみ始めた築古一棟もの
築40年前後の鉄筋コンクリートの一棟ビルを東京23区に3棟保有しています。
一般賃貸や民泊施設として運営していますが、さいきんは雨漏りなど修繕が必要になる建物が増えてきました。
線状降水帯のような大雨が続くと、屋根に負荷がかかり破損しやすくなります。
保険でカバーできるものとできないものがありますが、保険会社のスタンスによって対応が変わってきそうです。
さいきんは天災による被害が日本各地で発生しており、火災保険の加入費用も上昇していく傾向があります。
不動産を保有するコストは年々上昇しているので、それをカバーするだけの収益性が得られる価値ある物件を提供しなければいけないと考えています。
（つづく）
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
6　内藤忍のつぶやき
血糖値の測定始めました
健康状態のチェックのために、採血して血液検査をお願いしていますが、こんげつはそれに加えて、さらに血糖値の測定も始めました。
リブレという小さな端末を上腕に貼り付けて、血糖値の状態をリアルタイムで確認することができます。
血液検査と異なり数値の変化を確認できるのでどのようなタイミングで食べると、血糖値が急上昇するのかをチェックできます。
2週間データ測定して、血糖値の急上昇を防ぐような食生活の改善を医師にアドバイスしてもらいます。
週末はいかがお過ごしですか？
私は土曜日はインナーサークル資産設計実践会の月例会です。
今回も3組の専門家に登壇してもらい一般公開されていないようなインナーサークル情報をシェアする予定です。
皆様も素敵な週末をお過ごしください。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
資産デザイン研究所メールの解除・変更はこちらから
ご意見・ご感想・
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜免責事項＞
内藤忍資産デザイン研究所メール（以下「本メール」）は資産デザイン研究所（以下「当社」）が発行するメールマガジンです。
本メールの著作権は当社に属します。
複製・再配信等を行う場合は当社までご一報をお願いいたします。
掲載された内容は、執筆時における筆者の見解・予測であり、情報の正確性や完全性を保証しません。
こんご予告なく変更することがあります。
また、過去の実績は、将来の結果を保証するものでもありません。
本メールは情報提供のみを目的としており、投資の最終判断はお客さまご自身の判断と責任で行いますようお願いいたします。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。